[Music]
welcome back code vlogs episode six uh
season one episode six
and uh yeah this is a record of episode
six you're not going to see the original
one because
well reasons unmentioned anyway we're
continuing on with the project
and
yeah i guess you're just you're just
going to have to become a patron if you
want to know the reason because i posted
it there but uh yeah so consider
supporting me if you want to see all the
behind the scenes stuff that i post
uh not that this particular series is
sponsored
uh
by them but uh
it is what it is all right so i wanna
talk about a few little things here i've
that have changed mainly it's
well i've corrected the vc pkg json
manifest and i want to talk about the
errors i had originally so that you can
learn because they're kind of hard to
find
so you basically give the name of your
project it has to match this except
in this vc pkg json it has to be all
lowercase because reasons i don't know
it's just how they made it if
the whole problem i had like for months
was that this was capitalized
yeah let's not talk about it some reason
they want it lowercase
don't ask questions follow the rules all
right so basically you give i don't know
if this version string honestly matters
but that's the version of this library
right now so i put it
there
and you list all the dependencies now
these are the same that you search up
and resafe
vc pkg so you do it uh if you're not
sure exactly what's called you do a
search
for it and you find the exact name
am i blind okay yeah i'm blind it's
right there so i did that for all of
them and made sure they're all all
correct and
so this there's two different modes of v
say p kg gosh it's going to get old
saying that
it is so hard to find proper
documentation on this vc pkg i know they
have they even have a website for it and
they don't even have their uh okay
without complaining i'll try to explain
it because i literally can't find the
document where i found this explanation
anymore it's it's somewhere out there
okay so basically the normal way you use
vc pkg is the way i showed in my
original tutorial and that's basically
you install stuff
and then you use it
and it just works it's kind of globally
installed for all your stuff basically
once you do that integrate install thing
but
the other way of using it
and this is the manifest mode this is
called manifest mode and that's where
in your project structure you have a vc
pkg json
and it is this whole setup of what you
want to install for your project and
this is manifest mode and you also have
to put your project into manifest mode
so you right click on one of your top
level projects go to properties
find vcpkg under the configuration
properties as kind of the general
yeah so this uh configuration well these
first what five options
it doesn't matter which project you've
clicked on they're all the same
i think no that's not entirely true
looks like
well anyway
you click on the one that you want
to have libraries for
and you
make sure this use vcpg manifest is set
to yes because if it's no then it just
won't use it and it will just go off
your what i'm going to call global mode
because or normal mode global or normal
mode whatever the way you normally
install it
and this new way that i'm showing now is
the manifest mode so manifest mode is
great because it's project specific and
it's automatic you don't have to go type
in commands basically all you got to do
is hit build let me set this as i'll
just build this one and it'll do the
thing you don't see it here because i've
already built it but basically what it
does is it goes and fetches all the
libraries and if you have any errors
it'll tell you about them and you got to
correct it
and that's it so anyone who downloads
this project now that has vc pkg
installed the first time they hit build
it's going to grab all the libraries
automatically and just build you
literally don't have to do anything
except download and hit build
now well you do prerequisite you do have
to have these see pkg set up but that's
kind of a given if you're on windows you
probably already have it if you're a c
plus plus developer and if you don't you
should
all right so that was the big thing uh
the big thing i've changed here since
last episode i did take quite a long
break and i also added to the git ignore
all the stuff for vc pkg because it
tried to like include all my installed
libraries and everything it was it was a
nonsense mess and you would think that
you just go grab uh the one off yeah
maybe this is where i found the thing
all right so you think you know usually
what i do when i want to get ignore
globally for something that's pretty
common is i just search for good ignore
for whatever it is and you do that you
get the one from microsoft
but they do have a slight error in here
which
i'm not sure if it's supposed to be like
that or what so i'm still kind of
figuring that out
where is it
so this here
install
it's actually called vc pkg underscore
installed which
should be star in front of the installed
not after
so uh they kind of mess that up a little
bit i don't know if it's worth
correcting though because i could be
wrong but basically i just use this exa
these exact lines of code except i put
this star in front of installed so it
actually
ignored
the proper folder
which we can go see if we look at our
file explorer
and go here yeah it's this right here
like that's the one you want to ignore
they put the star in the wrong space so
just fyi if you get stuck there too and
wondering why their docs are wrong it's
because they are even big companies
screw up it's true
all right and what else have we changed
there's been a few other things
uh let's see i don't know if i talked
about a lot of this stuff but
yeah it's going to be a little better
with the libraries going forward and for
other people working on it it should
make a little more sense
other than that i was just kind of
moving around some things and testing
out some stuff
and there's not a whole lot of code
differences at the moment i'm kind of
still about where i was i'm working on
getting
the whole
thing set up back to its functional base
and it's it's still sort of a mess i
could fix it real quick if i wanted to
but it'd be back to being a fixed mess
which i guess is better than a broken
mess right so maybe i'll do that real
quick
uh maybe maybe because right now like uh
yeah if we run this right now
we still get just a blank window i've
only got one popping up it's going off
this example project now i've considered
removing this example project entirely
and uh moving most of the stuff that i
want to test just into a core test file
because that sort of makes more sense
really
it's just kind of hard to test the
windows popping up
and uh having to manually close it i
like tests to just be automatic and fly
through them
but in this case
it's hard to do that with like a graph
with a game engine type library you can
do it for a lot of the stuff but then
there's a lot of stuff where it's like
they depend on
you initializing previous stuff and so
how many times do you want to re-init
the same thing in your test
just to test one other thing
so there's there's some thoughts to
to this before i remove example project
but for now
example project is essentially
a true executable side project that just
uses this library
and that's just a way of testing it
and okay so i don't have a manifest on
for this because it uses
only the aaa engine but your project
might vary so one of the things i want
to do is get this to a state where
you can easily link
a a engine and build your own project
type of thing
and i do have a pretty big side project
in mind
that's uh in the deleted episode
uh previous episode six that i'm not
releasing because uh yeah i'm not happy
with it and i said some things that i
actually disagree with now so
yeah i guess that's
what happens but basically one of the
main things i was i talked about is
basically that
as you might guess by some of my recent
videos i'm moving away from game engine
development i'm moving more into game
development
because i am going to be working up a
game and i kind of like put some test
code and example project for the game i
want to make but the reality is
i
let me see if i can find these i don't
even know i might have deleted them
maybe it's the main character
that's all pretty much removed our main
game one of these has it player maybe
yeah like some some basic stats and
inventory stuff i was kind of starting
out with like armor resistance dodge you
know some some stuff you would expect in
in a game i started to kind of add that
in and i was like wait what am i doing
am i actually going to start making my
real game as this example project no
so the long-term goal is to move all the
test stuff into the actual test delete
example project that'll probably be next
episode
and then i want to have a total side
private project that you guys will
probably not see
because well it's private um
i don't know i might consider giving
access to like patrons or something but
really it's it's sort of like me
specific not code tech and tutorial
specific so it's sort of a different
uh scope i guess you would say i don't
know let me know what you think about
that down below
anything to get people to sign up on
patreon i don't want to have to cancel
this channel
oh geez do we i don't want to have that
talk either
really but uh
maybe maybe another time or during a
live cast or something
but yeah that's the thing just moving
into game development uh this engine
will still exist it's still my library
for building my my game but i'm only
going to work on it
insofar as it supports the game i'm
building
i don't want to add every feature
endlessly and try to do every little
thing because i'll just be here
endlessly kind of like i talked about
in that don't make a game engine
video
well uh yeah i guess not much coding
this time i've gotta actually kind of
reacquaint myself now that i've got this
manifest straight out that was the big
thing and just kind of getting
people updated on where i'm at and the
track of this
and uh what the plan is and they're also
i guess i will say there is even a
private version of ancient archer that
is i'm putting under my like main
company's name that will
basically be doing all the game dev
stuff
and yeah i i'm i'm a little mixed
between making it all private like
on one hand it's a little
bit much to
to put out every little piece of code
you do onto the internet because let's
face it coders some days your code is
like epic bad and you know you're gonna
not use it
and i'm basically doing that a lot of
days and i'm just putting it out there
anyway just for people to follow along
and learn from and have discussions but
i think there's only been
one or two comments on this whole series
so far but i am going to let it play out
i'm going to take probably a few days
off
and just kind of wait for it to sit for
a while and see how it does but
ultimately this first code vlog series
is a test if it does well we'll go for
season two
if it doesn't do well well
i i probably don't want to spend a whole
lot of time messing with it because uh
you kind of got to move on and just
learn from your failures that's the
reality of life
all right well thanks for watching guys
i'll see you in the next one matt out
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
you